madame monsieur bonsoir voici le titre
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal
ouverture de marseille du procès de la
scientologie cette responsable
comparaissent pour escroquerie un procès
déjà reporté en 95 et qui devrait se
dérouler après la disparition d'une
cinquantaine de pièces il y a dix ans
l'attentât du dc-10 d'uta au dessus du
niger la colère des familles des
victimes qui se sont retrouvés aux
invalides pour une cérémonie du souvenir
le timor oriental avec l'arrivée dans
quelques heures des premières troupes le
général commandant en chef de la force
de paix était à dili en reconnaissance
politique française invitée de ce
journal jack lang député maire de bois
et président de la commission des
affaires étrangères
et puis les indes galantes l opéra
garnier ce chef-d'oeuvre du xviiie de
jean philippe rameau revisitée par à
metteur en scène audacieuse mais ouvrons
ce journal avait que ce procès très
attendu de mme à la scientologie devant
la justice ou plus exactement sept de
ses responsables poursuivis pour
escroquerie
un procès dont on parlera plus d'un
titre d'abord parce qu'il a été reporté
une première fois en 95 et surtout de ma
il s'agira à l'ouverture de l'audience
de revenir sur la disparition ou plutôt
la destruction d'une cinquantaine de
pièces disparition considéré comme une
erreur ainsi s'exprime elisabeth guigou
garde des sceaux demain donc à marseille
un témoin à charge un homme qui s'est
constituée partie civile etc ont
rencontré joël bruandet jean yves blanc
et vincent des ombres le procès de
marseille repose sur cet homme parmi les
dix personnes qui avaient initialement
porter plainte
il est le seul à être allés jusqu'au
bout au départ raymond ce cas pilato
était simplement curieux
de chez vous le voir un peu comme un
défi ce qu'il en était de ce système qui
a - sastre était un peu de psychiatrie
l'histoire de raymond ce cas pilato
commence en décembre 89 lorsqu'il pousse
la porte de l'église de scientologie
et comme à chaque fois qu'un client
potentiel se présente on lui propose de
répondre à un inoffensif test de
personnalité 200 questions qui vont en
fait servir à débusquer les faiblesses
de la personne et donc à vanter les
solutions proposées par la scientologie
après le test viennent les livres les
cours
puis les séances d'audition très vite la
facture augmente astronomique est collé
à paris mettre en ordre les pistes du
passé les pistes du présent et cetera
moyennant le grand port raymond décide
de quitter la secte c'est alors qu'il
commence à recevoir coup de fil anonyme
et courriers intimidant cher raymond qui
me connaît mal
moi je te connais bien tu prends des
cours de pilotage a un air au club de
marseille d'émile tué réformée du
service militaire
ton téléphone risque d'être mis sur
écoutes sous peu d'autres renseignements
arrive et s'entassent dans ton dossier
l'instruction a duré dix ans dix longues
années qui ont permis à la justice de
comprendre que les responsables
marseillais de la scientologie
poursuivait un but bien éloignés de la
pratique d'un culte un but avant tout
financier ce que la scientologie réfute
même si jamais à titre d'hypothèse
d'école que ça puisse être trop cher
c'est à celui à qui la proposition est
faite de la refuser
mais les victimes comme raymond sont
elles vraiment en état de refuser
faut-il créer un délit de manipulation
mentale comme le préconisent certains
voient là une des nombreuses questions
qui devraient être abordés demain à
l'audience la colère et l'indignation
des familles des victimes qui ont perdu
la vie dans l'attentât du dc-10 d'uta
pour ce dixième anniversaire cérémonie
du souvenir avec une nouvelle fois
montrés du doigt comme responsable le
colonel kadhafi reportage yasmina farber
raymond chape l'arrêt rue des mathurins
fan officielle à cette cérémonie juste
les familles les amis des personnes
disparues dans l'explosion du dc 10
d'uta tous réunis devant un symbole une
sculpture dédiée aux victimes
d'attentats il ya dix ans la peine nous
a unis c'est elle encore qui nous
rassemblent aujourd'hui dix ans et
personne ne peut oublier les visages des
170 victimes passagers ou personnels
navigants le souvenir des images de
septembre 89 est omniprésent dans le
désert du niger des débris éparpillés
sur 50 kilomètres carrés l'armée qui
retrouve les corps c'est l'attentât le
plus meurtrier perpétré contre la france
des années d' enquête la reconstitution
de l'avion et le juge antiterroriste
jean louis bruguière remonte la piste
libyenne six fonctionnaires sont
impliqués dans l'attentât dont le beau
frère du colonel kadhafi ils ne
viendront pas à leur procès devant la
cour d'assises condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
ils sont aujourd'hui libres c'est au
prix de l'exécution des peines qui que
notre que nous considérerions conte puis
on peut tourner la page mais on ne peut
pas penser que ces six assassin vivent
tranquillement mais la diplomatie entre
la france et la libye a repris ses
droits
les familles elles continuent leur
combat elles ont porté plainte contre le
colonel kadhafi
mèneront jusqu'au bout tant que nous le
pourrons
cette plainte contre kadhafi s'il le
faut nous ferons reconnaître le
terrorisme comme crime contre l'humanité
pour qu'il n'y ait pas d'impunité pour
les terroristes
quel que soit le lieu où ils se cachent
quel que soit le temps qui s'écoule la
libye à verser 200 millions de francs
d'indemnités aux victimes de l'attentât
le colonel kadhafi estime aujourd'hui
que cette affaire est classée à toulouse
après l'explosion qui a totalement
détruit cet hôtel en plein centre de la
ville un tuyau de raccordement au gaz
sectionné a été retrouvé dans les
décombres
désormais désormais toutes les
hypothèses sont envisagées y compris un
acte criminel pour l'instant on n'en
sait pas davantage les secours pour leur
part ont interrompu leurs recherches en
toute fin d'après midi avec la certitude
qu'il n'y a plus de victimes sous les
gravats et puis en espagne cet accident
de car survenu dans le nord-est du pays
dans la province de saragosse 26
personnes ont été tuées d'autres sont
blessées pour des raisons encore
inconnues le bus a quitté la chaussée et
s'est renversé sur le bas-côté
la pluie pourrait peut-être être à
l'origine de ce drame cinquante deux
personnes étaient à bord au moment de la
si dans les personnes âgées toutes
espagnoles qui se rendaient en excursion
les secours tentent de dégager les
passagers bloqués la qualité à
l'étranger au timor oriental dans
quelques heures les premiers soldats de
la paix arriveront par avion a dit le
commandant en chef de cette force
multinationale a effectué dès ce matin
voyage de reconnaissance
quelques heures sur place avant de
revenir avec son état major au complet
la question maintenant est de savoir
s'il y aura coopération totale de la
part de l'armée indonésienne
jérôme venu c'est maintenant sur les
épaules de cet homme que reposent les
espoirs de paix au timor oriental le
général cosgrove commandant australien
de la force d'intervention des nations
unies il a fait ce matin une brève
visite préparatoire à dili pour
rencontrer le général indonésien
administrateur de la loi martiale au
timor l'armée indonésienne accepte de
passer la main le général cosgrove se
veut optimiste
il affirme que la coopération est très
bonne avec les indonésiens mais il sait
que les risques d'accrochage viennent
des milices anti indépendantistes il est
difficile de dire si les milices qui ont
initié la violence atroce du timor
oriental seront tentés de se faire la
main contre une force militaire moderne
mon souhait sincère quand on essaye pas
oui nous sommes prêts à riposter de
façon rigoureuse à la force si elle est
utilisée contre nous étrange chassé
croisé sur l'aéroport de delhi
l'armée indonésienne abandonne la place
alors même que le premier avion d' aide
humanitaire arrive dans les rues de la
ville les traces évidentes des violences
qui ont fait des centaines de morts
depuis le vote de lille pour
l'indépendance fin août
aujourd'hui les milices anti
indépendantistes sont encore actifs
la mission des casques bleus pourrait
être périlleuse leurs compagnes le
savent
dans quelques heures arriveront au
timor-oriental les premiers avions d'un
pont aérien qui devraient acheminer près
de 3000 hommes dans la semaine parmi eux
500 français qui auront pour première
mission d'installer une antenne
chirurgicale près de l'aéroport de delhi
ce sont les premiers éléments de la
force de paix française baptisée sans
talent
dont la vocation est essentiellement
humanitaire au kosovo le désarmement de
lucie k doit prendre effet à minuit
précises mais des négociations se sont
poursuivies toute la journée entre la
kfor et l'armée de libération du kosovo
en fin de journée les discussions
bloquaient encore sur des détails dit on
ferait des responsables de la force de
l'otan
aucune déclaration publique ni le
général jackson commandant de la kfor ni
bernard kouchner ne souhaite s'exprimer
avant un accord complet total sur ce
texte
d'importants mouvements de troupes à la
frontière de la tchétchénie plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'hommes s'apprête
à lancer une offensive de grande
envergure pour éliminer d'après les
autorités russes les extrémistes
islamistes considérés comme responsables
de la vague d'attentats qui touche la
russie ces dernières semaines françois
gelez l'idée de l'état-major russe et
d'isoler complètement la tchétchénie
objectif isoler les rebelles islamistes
réfugiés dans cette petite république
indépendantiste et les russes ne lésine
pas sur les moyens
ils seraient 30 mille soldats déployés
entre la frontière de la tchétchénie et
du daguestan
pour l'instant certains de ces
militaires sont employés à contrôler des
réfugiés mais il pourrait aussi se
préparer à une opération d'envergure sur
le territoire tchétchène
depuis sept jours l'aviation russe
bombarde sans répit des villages
considérés comme des bases de rebelles
touchant des zones habitées où la
population ne comprend pas pourquoi elle
est devenue une cible
croyez moi a dit cette femme je vous
parle franchement comme une mère ce ne
sont pas des rebelles que vous tuez ici
et si moscou justifie ses frappes pour
prévenir de nouvelles actions des
islamistes tchétchènes au daguestan
moscou est également convaincu que la
vague de terrorisme qui frappe le pays
trouve son origine ici l'an teaching
alors à grozny la capitale de la petite
république indépendantiste population
soldats tchétchènes protestent ou prie
le ciel d'être épargné par les
bombardements russes la suite des
élections régionales en allemagne le
paraît deux parties de gerhard schröder
enregistre une déroute électorale sans
précédent le plus bas score dans un
scrutin régional depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale selon du mois les
premiers résultats en saxe le pape jean
paul ii ans le veniez une visite
pastorale d'une journée dans cette ex
république yougoslave
le saint père à l'occasion d'une
cérémonie de béatification a plaidé pour
une europe débarrassée des nationalismes
extrêmes sur place alain salma et
dominique marlins un promeneur pas comme
les autres cet après-midi dans les rues
de maribor jean paul ii traverse la
petite place de la cathédrale pour se
recueillir devant la tombe d'un prêt la
slovène du siècle dernier
monseigneur choc chèque qui l'a proclamé
bienheureux le matin même devant
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes
monseigneur chaume tchèque symbole d'une
nation alors occupé par l'autriche
un homme qui s'est beaucoup battu pour
la la permanence de la culture slovène
et de la langue slovène mais il faut
dire il n'a pas écrit une ligne heures
contre le peuple allemand
et c'est précisément parce que le
nouveau bienheureux est le symbole d'un
nationalisme tolérant que jean paul ii a
tenu à faire une fois encore le voyage
dansé balkans secoué dit-il par c'est
effarant nettoyage ethnique
le patriotisme sincère proclame-t-il
doit se conjuguer avec le respect de
l'autre de sa nationalité de sa culture
et de sa religion
applaudissements de la foule qui
n'oublie pas que jean paul ii a été le
premier à reconnaître l'indépendance de
la slovénie
première étape de la désintégration de
l'ex-yougoslavie d intégration qui n'a
pas été particulièrement marquée par
cette tolérance que proclamée jadis
monseigneur chaume tchèque ce voyage de
maribor ne constitue que la première
escale d'un marathon d'automne
particulièrement chargé et fatigante
pour le pape
en novembre elle sera en inde et géorgie
et en décembre en irak et au sinaï
sur les traces d'abraham les as voyages
qui lui permettra aussi de serrer la
main de saddam hussein
retour en france le grand toilettage la
sncf ou du moins pour les trains de
banlieue qui circulent en ile-de-france
à nouveau look un nouveau nom on les
appellera désormais les transilien et un
effort de modernisation que nous dévoile
pascal golomer et m'a dit diawara avec
ses panneaux d'affichage masquer la sncf
fait aujourd'hui dans le secret car
c'est demain seulement qu'elle entend
des voix l'air ici en gare d'asnières
le nouveau look de son réseau banlieue
un mot qui disparaîtra d'ailleurs de son
vocabulaire trop ringard dit elle dit
désormais transilien c'est plus chic
un logo ou plutôt un label de qualité
réservée aux lignes qui ont été
modernisées un vaste chantier de cinq
ans pour réaménager les 220 gares les
plus fréquentées rénové 3800 voiture du
sol au plafond et motivés aussi les dix
neuf mille cheminots qui travaillent
tous les jours sur ce réseau la sncf le
sait l'une des principales
préoccupations des voyageurs et des
agents d'île de france c'est la sécurité
côté emploi la création de 800 postes
supplémentaires dont 400 emplois jeunes
avaient déjà été annoncées l'an dernier
la direction s'engage également à
maintenir les gares ouvertes jusqu'à ce
que le dernier train soit passé et les
60 gares les plus sensibles seront
placés sous vidéosurveillance d'ici à
le cliquetis de la sncf c'est bien sûr
de redorer l'image trop négative de ce
réseau encore faut-il pour cela
améliorer aussi la régularité des trains
exercice bien plus difficile que de
dessiner un nouveau logo aujourd'hui
comme chaque année depuis 15 ans se sont
déroulées les virades de l'espoir
organisées par l'association de lutte
contre la mucoviscidose cette maladie
génétique grave la plus fréquente des
maladies génétiques chez l'enfant avec
le soutien de france télévisions plus de
300 virades se déroule en france
aujourd'hui comme celle du parc de
sceaux dans les hauts-de-seine que vous
avez donc vu sur ces images
au chapitre judiciaire jean michel
boucheron l'ancien député-maire
socialiste comparaît demain angoulême où
il devra répondre de malversations
financières cet homme déjà condamné une
première fois à 14 à quatre ans de
prison pour la banqueroute
de sa ville et qui accusaient à l'époque
un déficit de 164 millions de francs cet
homme qui a purgé un peu plus d'un an et
demi de détention se dit prêt
aujourd'hui assumer ses erreurs une
personnalité trouble à multiples
facettes qu'on rencontrait françois
privat et filles britten un flambeur
amoureux des voitures de collection dans
les années 80 c'est ainsi que ses
détracteurs définissent jean michel
boucheron alors maire ps d'angoulême
aujourd'hui agent commercial à bordeaux
cet homme de 53 ans affirme avoir tourné
la page de la politique et payer sa
dette
après une condamnation à 4 années
d'emprisonnement dont deux avec sursis
j'ai fait ce que j'ai fait fait de la
politique j'ai commis l'erreur j'ai
aussi fait des choses qui je crois sont
bonnes j'ai payé pour ses erreurs je les
assume je ne regrette rien au sens je
veux pas passer mon temps dira si
j'avais su bon dieu boucheron ce que
t'as été con non c'est ainsi c'est ainsi
que 20 92 jean michel boucheron toujours
député joue les jacques médecin de
gauche pour une cabale en argentine
comme il le définit lui-même durant
quatre ans il vit à buenos aires avec sa
compagne agnès ouvrant même un
restaurant de cuisine française mars 97
l'ancien maire d'angoulême décide de
rentrer en france on savait bien au fond
de nous même qu'il faudrait un jour ou
l'autre purger la situation judiciaire
avec ce que ça impliquait puisque
j'avais une lourde condamnation
et puis il y avait aussi une autre
situation c'est celle d'un enfant qui
avait deux ans dont on se rendait bien
compte qu'on ne lui offre pas d'avenir
vrai dès son retour c'est la prison à la
santé puis un procès à paris en juin 97
et une condamnation pour abus de biens
sociaux et recel d'au moins cinq cent
quarante mille francs
la sphère boucheron a été traitée de 83
89 dans tous ses coins et recoins par
paris et la condamnation lourde
là quatre ans de prison dans deux années
ferme c'est paris qui la donnent froid
c'est l'essentiel a été vu la ultima
volet de la faire demain à angoulême
jean michel boucheron comparaît pour
s'expliquer sur des détournements de
fonds constaté lors de la construction
d'un incinérateur et d'une station
d'épuration en périphérie de
l'agglomération charentaise je rentrerai
pas en cachant comme un voleur gm
expliqué j'ai à défendre
très clairement ce que je pense c'est ce
que j'ai cru faire voilà au delà de
l'enjeu judiciaire le symbole un ancien
maire comparé dans sa ville en corse le
retour de la violence après ces cinq
attentats à l'explosif qui se sont
produits simultanément dans la nuit de
vendredi à samedi dans les milieux
nationalistes l'émergence du mouvement
clandestin armata corsa qui avait
revendiqué l'assassinât d'un comme une
bouchée jette un certain trouble
troubles entretenues par la conférence
de presse clandestine du flnc qui
s'engageait à reprendre les actions
violentes
audi vétérans et frédéric besson ont
rencontré françois s'en tenait une des
figure du nationalisme corse
voici sa réaction on le disait un peu
retiré des affaires nationaliste mais
depuis quelques semaines il est au
centre de toutes les conversations
françois santoni figure musclée du
nationalisme corse
ancien secrétaire du parti là qu'on
coule d'indépendantistes dément avoir
créé avec un autre nationaliste
historique jean michel rossi armata
corsa armata corsa c'est le groupe armé
clandestin qui a déjà revendiqué de
nombreux attentats et un meurtre
ahmat accord ça a aussi fait voler en
éclats la tentative d'unification des
mouvements nationalistes armes à savoir
c'est très simple tiens et sourds qui
mes proches c'est exact discours où elle
comme dame affaire erignac ont ils dit
nous ne soutenons pas les hommes c'est
vrai pour les autres je soutiendrai
jamais je dire chacun doit assumer ses
actes c'est tout aujourd'hui moi je dis
non l'action militaire
françois santoni ne pense pas que la
guerre entre nationalistes soit déclarée
les mouvements clandestins n'y aurait
aucun intérêt
il condamne la violence mais ils
refusent de s'associer à l'initiative du
comité du fiumorbu un rassemblement de
13 partis nationalistes qui avaient pour
but de s'unir pour faire avancer leurs
idées sur la voie politique françois
santoni voudrait que le nationalisme se
recompose complètement le nationalisme
aujourd'hui devrait carrément faire un
aggiornamento détruire toutes les
structures existantes dire que des maris
peut-être sur un nouveau mouvement une
fédération nouveau monde pluraliste
françois santoni n'aura peut être pas le
temps de jouer les premiers rôles dans
ce nouveau mouvement il sera jugé en
janvier prochain pour tentative
d'extorsion de fond raquettes
il risque 10 ans de prison politique
française avec d'abord cette déclaration
de dominique voynet chez nos confrères
de rtl la ministre de l'environnement
écarté l'idée d'un recentrage de lionel
jospin à l approche des élections
présidentielles par ailleurs de
migraines et s'est dit choqué du rejet
par le premier ministre de l'idée de
proportionnelle je vous propose l écoute
et puis il y pas beaucoup le programme
de son parti aux élections
présidentielles par exemple jamais ça
vous choque
mais oui ça me choque les accords sont
faits pour être respecté en même temps
leur mais en même temps je crois que on
a on est pas en train d'utiliser les à
court terme vers socialiste comme une
sorte de feuille de route appliquée de
façon maniaque et procédurière le
dialogue a lieu entre deux partis tous
les jours ils n'avaient pas dû
suffisamment avant l'été et nous l'avons
dit nous avons besoin de renforts
j'emprunte régulièrement je vois que un
bilan a été fait des accords fehr ps
entre les verts et le parti socialiste
il ya quelques semaines et nous avons
listé les points où les avancées ont été
positives et puis nous avons listé les
points sur lesquels nous attendons plus
aigu du gouvernement et puis edouard
balladur invité de l'émission dimanche
midi sur france 2 est revenu sur
l'annoncé des suppressions d'emplois
chez michelin voilà ce que pouvait dire
l'ancien premier ministre rpr je vous
propose à ses lecteurs
je dis ceci une entreprise si on veut
qu'elle marche vraiment doit être aussi
une fune communauté morale d'une
communauté de destin et ça suppose qu'un
certain
nombre de règles de comportement soit
respectée la première d'entre elles
étant me semble t'il d'informer et de
discuter pour que je vends n'apprennent
pas les choses qui leur tombe sur la
tête inopinément et bien je souhaite que
l'on prenne toutes les mesures
nécessaires pour bien expliquer et
surtout pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait
le moins de licenciements possibles
jack lang bonsoir on doit bien la sphère
michelin est dans tous les esprits
je sais aussi dans dans le vôtre la
semaine dernière vous vous disiez plutôt
intéressé par la proposition de robert
hue de rétablir l'autorisation en forme
en tout cas l'interdiction provisoire de
licenciement lionel jospin dit
clairement qu'ils étaient sur une autre
voie il a eu tort
d'abord il n'ya pas que michelin il ya
beaucoup d'autres licenciements abusifs
ailleurs en france je pense en
particulier à épée da dans le
département de loir et cher où l'on
jette sur le pavé des travailleurs
brutalement on ruine des familles ont
ruiné toute une région et cette
inacceptable
il y arriver a nommé il ya une réalité
d'un cynisme aveugle et sauvage pour ne
peut pas accepter et se joue en effet
une partie de bras de fer entre d'un
côté le pouvoir politique
démocratiquement élu et d'autre part la
dictature des marchés financiers ou le
comportement de certains patrons alors
ça voilà pour la philosophie et on a
compris le real importe maintenant ce
que je crois que dans ce débat il faut
que nous puissions réussir à obtenir que
les travailleurs soient pleinement
respectés
il ne peut pas y avoir de licenciements
sans aucun risque en pause et voulez
bien je crois que je n'ai que ce soit
contre une économie administrée ou mais
s'est fait quelques propositions contre
aussi une économie administrée jeu
d'ailleurs je suis sur la même ligne que
le premier ministre compte vraiment
c'est pas toujours à la salle vers un
tel ou tel nuance ici ou là je crois que
nous ne sommes pas complètement désarmé
et si nous le sommes alors il faut
mettre au point de nouvelles mesures par
exemple si le dialogue avec les patrons
ne réussit pas alors il y a imaginé des
sanctions des entreprises fautives
par exemple une surcotisation des
entreprises
aux différents fonds de financement du
chômage c'est normal qu'elles apportent
une contribution au financement du
chômage ou bien encore il faut songer à
supprimer certaines aides publiques
parfois excessive accordée à des
entreprises qui ne font pas assez pour
l'emploi donc clairement vous dites que
là vous n'abandonnez pas le combat que
vous faites un certain nombre de
propositions vous dites que ce n'est pas
à l'état de payer mais aux entreprises
aux enfants bien sûr mais il ya eu
profit voyez par exemple dans l'histoire
de michelin à la bourse leur action
grimper lors d'un pétard voyez ce qui se
passe avec ce texte patron qui pour son
licenciement obtenu paraît-il 200
millions de francs c'est deux poids deux
mesures d'un côté des patrons qui qui
bénéficie d' de ressources et avait une
cellule très importante de la part de
l'état et puis de l'autre les
travailleurs jetés à la rue si je
comprends bien une obligation de
reclassement de ces personnes qui sont
licenciées
est-ce que sur la sphère épée dames par
exemple vous allez aller sur le terrain
est ce que j'allais participer à des
mesures ayant enregistré les uns les
autres bien entendu je suis aux côtés de
ceux qui ont été licenciés je souhaite
leur reclassement est en tout cas la
reconsidération la situation alors si je
vous ai bien compris cette semaine
et si je vous ai lu ici ou là vous
disiez en clair que la france n'avait
été jamais si prospère une belle
croissance
quand même temps elle faisait pas
forcément les bons choix je pense là aux
budgets je pense à l'impôt vous n'êtes
pas très ravie au fond qu'on ait choisi
de baisser la tva et qu'en revanche on
n'est pas touché à la taxe d'habitation
ce que ça veut dire que là aussi vous
prenez vos distances vis-à-vis de la pio
les gens qui avaient tous trois du
gouvernement aime rappeler l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est que grâce à l'actuel
gouvernement
la france est un pays est redevenu
prospère et la croissance et l'emploi
sont au rendez vous et je crois que tout
le mérite en revient au premier ministre
raison de plus pour être sur le front
social plus plus active pour lutter
contre l'inégalité sociale
je pense au chômage des jeunes en
difficulté je pense au chômage de longue
durée
je pense aux quartiers en difficulté
c'est un anneau de la politique nous
avons actuellement engagés depuis une
dizaine d'années est dans une impasse et
il faut revoir les choses
entièrement et je suis le pressentiment
que le premier ministre s'apprête à
prendre des décisions qui vont pouvoir
donner un nouveau
souffle à la politique des quartiers en
difficulté vous feriez un bon ministre
de la ville en question est un très bon
ministre actuellement qui mène ce combat
simplement il faut lui donner les
structures les moyens et l'organisme
voit un peu partout parce qu'au passage
il ya un sondage cette semaine
vous étiez le champion toutes catégories
comme candidat potentiel en tout cas
d'après ce sondage à la mairie de paris
vous avez évidemment pas me répondre
franchement ça me tenterait probablement
pas franchement je suis maire de blois
et je suis très heureux d'être maire de
blois simplement que j'appelle par la
question oui mais oui mais c'est la
vérité
simplement je personnellement je
souhaite que pour les grandes villes de
france et notamment paris le parti
auquel appartient le parti socialiste
prenne des décisions tout à fait
nouvelle en particulier en finisse avec
le cumul des mandats le futur maire de
paris sans attendre la loi sans attendre
la loi
je crois que le futur candidat à la
mairie de paris de la gauche devra
prendre l'engagement de se consacrer
totalement pendant les cinq ou six ans
qui viennent à cette fonction de maire
sans aucune autre ambition de même je
souhaite que sur les listes les listes
de gauche aux prochaines élections
municipales il y ait réellement 50% de
femmes une présence de jeunes qui c'est
l'avenir des jeunes qui se joue
notamment dans les communes et et l'udc
et une réduction à 5 ans de la durée des
mandats et en vous êtes temps jack lang
on a l'impression que c'est tout un
programme que vous proposez on n'a pas
le temps ici de le développer si vous
lui bien rester avec nous on parlera
dans quelques instants du patrimoine
revenons à présent sur la rentrée
scolaire avec comme chaque année
l'inquiétude des parents qui se
préoccupe du poids du cartable de leurs
enfants un sujet à prendre au sérieux
quand on sait que plus de la moitié des
adolescents se plaignent de mal de dos
selon une enquête récente je vous
propose de suivre cette expérience
unique en france
le collège jean moulin de perpignan
alléger le cartable en découpant les
livres scolaires elsa margot et jean
yves blanc fait montrer un peu la lure
cartons d'eau alors août est grande
tous les mois c'est quinze élèves de 5e
sont pesé mesuré inspectés sous toutes
les coutures
3 où il participe à une expérience
unique en france leur cartable pèse 5
fois moins lourd que celui de leurs
camarades
et pour cause les manuels scolaires ont
été singulièrement allégée objectives
comme ça qu'ils ont essayé de couper et
c'est pour avoir le cartable plus léger
et toi tu t'en sers comment alors un
prêt samedi deux ans le prince où ni
quand même très saine du drame laisse à
ce qu'il le ramène ils ont laissé au
chili etc pour avoir pour avoir collé le
court bien former un cartable de collet
vient pèse une dizaine de kilos en
moyenne à l'âge où les enfants sont en
pleine croissance un problème évoqué
chaque année sans que soit avancé de
solution au collège jean moulin on a
donc choisi d'agir en découpant les
livres
cette classe a vécu l'expérience l'an
dernier la moitié des élèves avaient un
cartable normal l'autre un cartable
allégé début peser on va dire 8 9 kilos
et certains ligier 2,3 kg c'est moins
bon pour le dos mais c'est lourd pour la
tête parce qu'il faut toujours penser à
prendre facilement ces fascicules les
faits et tout ce à quoi le suivi médical
est en tout cas concluant avec le
cartable alléger les enfants sont moins
fatigués leurs croissances plus
régulières mais l'expérience se limite à
une seule classe en passant en cinquième
les élèves ont retrouvé un cartable
normal succès confirmé pour les journées
du patrimoine vous êtes plus de 11
millions à vous être rendu un peu
partout en france à la découverte de
monuments historiques bâtiments
officiels ou simple lieu de vie en forme
de bilan cette promenade guidée que vous
proposez rares dalmat zéro-g mathurin
document exceptionnel la caméra en
correctionnelle ça al'allure du vrai ça
n'est pas du vrai coupable comédiens
d'un jour un avocat stagiaire une
ambiance grave
pourtant elle suscite des vocations qui
veut être avocat qui veut être juge le
palais de justice de grenoble a joué à
fond les journées du patrimoine et de la
citoyenneté en montrant le
fonctionnement des audiences autres
prétoire celui qui renaît de ses cendres
de février 94
le parlement de rennes les bretons sont
venus nombreux retrouver leur chair
palais 450 millions de francs de
restauration de modernisation
intelligente du bâtiment datant de 718
la cour d'appel va s'y réinstaller dès
début octobre
je vais vous lire un discours claude
piéplu figurait parmi les comédiens
réputé qui ce week end un peu partout en
france ont lu des textes faisant partie
de l'héritage national
cela se passait ce matin dans une
université fondée il ya sept cent
cinquante ans par robert de sorbon la
sorbonne qui a vu passer nombre de
grands citoyens
la trame est la chaîne au fil des
métiers la manufacture des gobelins a dû
faire face à l'aso curieux de milliers
de visiteurs pendant les deux jours les
lissiers se font toujours un plaisir
d'expliquer leur savoir faire celui de
la grande tradition manière et matières
d'ailleurs colbert surveille de loi les
gobelins l'un de ses établissements
préférées idem pour le public
cinq mille personnes par jeu ministère
des affaires étrangères ouverture du
premier étage première pour les curieux
fabuleuse salle de bain privée aménagé
pour le roi george vi en 1938 lors des
prochaines journées
on espère pouvoir découvrir d'autres
coulisses la salle des codes secrets ou
les cuisines le quai d'orsay nous met en
appétit
jack lang évidemment un mot sur vous
deux bébés les journées du patrimoine
que vous avez créé puis la technoparade
deuxième édition l'impression que ces
bébés se portent bien
j'ai l'impression que j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ont bien grandi tout en restant
fidèles à leur esprit premier bon je le
peux c'est la culture sans avec au delà
des étiquettes obtient sur la nature est
un tout l'histoire d'un côté le futur de
l'autre et on est toujours un peu ému de
notre devoir cesser millions de
personnes découvrir leur histoire les
couvrir leurs monuments qui leur
appartiennent et qui sont restaurés avec
l'argent des français et puis de l'autre
des jeunes participer à cette communion
collective à ce goût de la fête
moi je crois que dans cette période qui
est parfois un peu troublé il regagne
plus réjouissant que l appétit de
connaissances a soif de beauté le désir
de partager
je crois que cela doit encourager les
pouvoirs publics on a aussi levé les
serments d'autres initiatives prises et
a continué à reprendre ce beau slogan de
n'a guère changé la vie bon ça aussi ce
sera peut-être l'occasion de vous
réécouter devrait inviter merci jack
lang opéra ballet avec la création d un
de galan de jean philippe rameau un
chef-d'oeuvre de la musique du xviiie
siècle revisité avec audace sur la scène
de l'opéra garnier
depuis près de 35 ans ce spectacle
n'était plus elle affiche en france
découverte avec antoine cormery et
bernard en fait dans les coulisses de
l'opéra c'est parfois un peu comme dans
les stands de formule 1 au moment
fatidique des ravitaillements
482 costumes et jusqu'à huit changements
par personnage les indes galantes sont
l'une des plus grosses et des plus
fastueuses production de l'opéra de
paris
top chrono c'est parti pour un
changement express en moins de quatre
minutes les petits marquis du prologue
vont se muer en turc à la mode 18e
vous êtes diplômé e ou non mais j'ai pas
tout ça à faire le matin je me lève très
tôt elle avait tout le temps
vive l'exotisme et les voyages lointains
les indes galantes de rameau nous emmène
dans un tourbillon dim des music halls
vivre des histoires d'amour chez les
turcs les incas du pérou les perses et
les sauvages d'amérique
auquel cas la femme la tnt est occupée
comme moi comme un show les lots ou
quasi nulle part c'est à dire les
entrées très contrastées plein dedans
lui et avec cette insistance sur le
mouvement
et le mouvement il est admirablement
réglé par la jeune chorégraphe espagnole
blanca li qui parvient à l'harmonie en
jouant le décalage complet danse moderne
et musique baroque
mais le mouvement il est aussi en
coulisses surtout quand comme natalie
dessay on incarne trois personnages
c'est un spectacle qui est fait pour le
plaisir de l'est le plaisir de l'oreille
du début à la fin
vous vous sentez mulder vous aux meneurs
de revue pas vraiment mais disons que
des revues de cette qualité moi j'aime
bien tous les jours
ainsi se termine cette édition je vous
rappelle les deux principaux titres que
nous avons développé le timor-oriental
avec l'arrivée dans quelques heures des
premières troupes le général commandant
en chef des forces de l'apec est établie
en reconnaissance le puits ouverture de
marseille du procès de la scientologie
cette responsable comparaissent pour
escroquerie un procès déjà reporté en 95
qui devrait se dérouler malgré la
disparition d'une cinquantaine de pièces
dans un instant la météo présentée par
nathalie rihouet à 20h50 l'urgence suivi
d'un très beau documentaire de dominique
torrès sur la mucoviscidose dernière
édition florence duprat 23h35 de mal
dans les 4 vérités à 7h50 françoise
laborde recevra pierre moscovici
ministre délégué aux affaires
européennes à 20h vous retrouverez que
la série ans
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
e